a woman walks through the lonely hills
in the dead of night her purple sari is
torn and filthy from days of exposure to
the elements her bare feet have been cut
up and bruised by the rough terrain she
walks but her clothes and feet are not
the most noticeable thing about her this
woman is pregnant her belly swollen two
freakish proportions it's frankly a
miracle that she's even able to walk in
this state she stumbles and sways under
the weight of the thing growing inside
her whatever it is it's too large to be
any kind of ordinary baby but she keeps
moving muttering to herself in a
language that no human ear has heard in
years her eyes are glazed over almost
hypnotized she moves with great purpose
but her vacant facial expression makes
it appear as though she doesn't know
exactly what that purpose is she just
needs to keep moving further into the
wilderness until it happens whatever it
is the one thing that's certain is that
it isn't anything good a car rumbles
down a nearby dirt road it's being
driven by dr vinay ramachadran a medical
practitioner from the nearby city of
surah who occasionally drives out to the
more rural areas where the locals might
not have easy access to medical help he
spots the staggering woman and
immediately pumps the brakes of his car
she's clearly in need of medical
attention thank goodness he happened to
be driving by at the time dr ramasharan
grabs his medical bag from the back seat
and rushes towards the woman who
collapses in a heap before he reaches
her that's when to his utter horror dr
ramacharan notices that the woman's
belly is continuing to swell at an
unnatural rate even for a woman who is
heavily pregnant with triplets this
would still be far too large and the
rate at which she's swelling is akin to
someone blowing up a balloon by the time
dr ramasharan reaches her the worst has
already happened the woman's belly has
burst open and crouching on her corpse
is the thing that was growing inside her
an adult man
nude and covered in blood dr
ramasharan's terror only increases when
he notices that the man is eating her
elsewhere a riot is unfolding in the
streets a megaphone wielding instigator
barks orders for violence and chaos as
the rioters spread setting fires
smashing windows and attacking any
unfortunate civilians caught in their
way it's one of the worst riots that the
area has ever seen even the veteran riot
cops are frightened by the ferocity of
it the cops descend and clash with the
crowd of ever-advancing rioters they're
beaten back with crowbars baseball bats
knives and metal pipes and behind them
all the instigator continues spitting
his venomous words working the crowd
into an unmatchable frenzy they'll need
heavy reinforcements if they want to get
this riot under control that's when one
of the riot cops on the front line
sergeant abhishek notices something
strange so many of the rioters seem to
have the exact same face the face of the
instigator another place another time
four men are digging up a grave in a
desolate old graveyard they work
tirelessly all moving in perfect
synchronicity they're only interrupted
when a group of heavily armed men crash
the party and start firing on them but
these grave robbers are prepared all of
them draw revolvers like a gang in an
old western and begin returning fire
causing the men in tactical gear to seek
cover behind the nearby tombstones while
one of the grave robbers continues to
fire the other three scatter during the
confusion when his gun runs dry with
that tell-tale click the men in tactical
gear immediately rise up and pin cushion
him with shot after shot of their
assault rifles he does the bullet dance
like tony montana and collapses to the
ground but when the gunmen approach to
confirm the kill there's a horrifying
twist of fate swarms of horrible red
flies start pouring out of every bullet
wound swarming the attackers who retreat
swatting away these horrible little
insects but there's so many of them
there's no way to stop at least some of
them from crawling into their mouths
here's an interesting fact all of these
nightmarish incidents are connected in
the year 1969 a mysterious man was
arrested in himatnakar an area in the
indian state of gujarat this man had
been accused of inciting civil unrest
terrorizing and distressing the local
people he was later extradited to an
unknown location after the indian
authorities received a request from a
mysterious organization known as yep you
guessed it the scp foundation who could
this man have possibly been to attract
such attention the authorities thought
it best not to question it they were
probably just glad to be rid of the
troublemaker once and for all
except they weren't not by a long shot a
few years later in 1975 a group of four
men were discovered in a cemetery this
time in ahmedabad another location in
gujarat india for desecrating graves
this would be strange and upsetting
enough but what really sent things to
the next level weirdness was the
discovery that these four men were all
the same man each one was not only
genetically identical to one another but
also to the man that had been extradited
in 1969
you'd be more than justified in asking
what the hell is going on here maybe
there were just a group of highly rare
quintuplets five children all born from
the same mother who just happened to
have a predilection towards crime and
antisocial behavior or perhaps something
stranger was afoot the four who appeared
in the cemetery might have been clones
of the original troublemaker in
himnathagar as relatively simple as
those explanations would be the truth
was in fact far far weirder than mad
science or coincidentally criminal
quintuplets the four from the cemetery
had been ambushed by operatives of the
global occult coalition another shadowy
organization fans of this channel are
likely to recognize the coalition or goc
is a group that views itself as the
police of the paranormal world using
extremely advanced technology to destroy
supernatural entities and artifacts
rather than contain them they've been
known to work both alongside and against
the scp foundation both groups combined
interest in four genetically identical
men in an indian graveyard seemed to
suggest there was something supernatural
about their origin one of the men had
been killed by the goc while the
remaining three were taken into custody
by the scp foundation gotta love the
power of teamwork but who were these men
where had they come from and why did
they share identical genes to the first
man from six years earlier could there
have been even more of them well in the
years following the foundation has been
able to determine that yes there are
more of these genetically identical
individuals out there across the more
rural states of india like gujarat
rajasthan himachal pradesh haryana
punjab jammu and kashmir there may be
over a thousand instances of the same
person collectively they are known as
scp-2833
while their outward appearance can vary
somewhat instances of scp-2833 all share
the exact same genetic traits as each
other depending on the area they are
located in these anomalous people can
speak various languages and regional
dialects including hindi english
gujarati dogiri kashmiri punjabi urdu
and even an outdated unknown language
that doesn't correspond with any known
modern dialect or language family each
scp-2833 also possesses the ability to
manipulate the organic matter of their
own body now we don't mean that these
men will stretch themselves like mr
fantastic or turn into something out of
john carpenter's the thing but they're
able to use their bodies to create
well
something
scp-2833 instances can produce a small
anomalous parasite known as scp-2833-a
these are often released through any
bodily orifice like the mouth nose or
ears or through any cuts or open wounds
suffered by an scp-2833
in other words if you shot and killed in
scp-2833
perhaps in a cemetery under the orders
of the global coats coalition then these
parasites would still be able to escape
through the victims bullet wounds the
only way to stop this from happening is
to incinerate the body of a deceased
scp-2833
burning them until there is nothing left
so what exactly are these parasites well
they're tiny invertebrates meaning
they're a small cold-blooded organism
with no spine that can live on land or
in water they closely resemble
diptyrions which are any order of
insects that contain what we know as
flies red in color and 20 millimeters in
length
scp-2833
are composed of a combination of muscle
tissue keratin the protein that your
hair skin and fingernails are made from
and traces of ash strangely enough they
are also capable of flying with their
two wings and will use these to attempt
to enter the body of a suitable host
while this can be any vertebrate
creature it seems they have a preference
for humans once inside the host's body
an
scp-2833-a parasite will attach itself
to their nervous system this then allows
the scp-2833 instance that the parasite
originated from to control the body of
the host taking over their bodily and
motor functions nervous system and all
of their sensory organs from here an
scp-2833 will then either subject the
target to vivid inescapable
hallucinations or manipulate the
functions of their body the parasites
also contain a miniature instance of
another
scp-2833 only about two millimeters long
while these mini scp-2833s are usually
chemically inactive lying dormant and
unable to move this changes if the
parasite's host is a human female in
these cases the
scp-2833-a creature will implant the
miniature
scp-2833 within the uterus of their
female host after this the new
scp-2833 will begin to rapidly grow
consuming any and all organic matter
that surrounds it once again the
scp-2833 that the parasite originated
from is still able to manipulate the
female host's body and will use this
control to make her leave her home and
travel away from any urban environment
after a year this new instance of
scp-2833 will be born in a truly
horrific fashion every time this happens
the female host is unable to survive the
process dying as a result of being used
as an incubator for the parasites the
newly formed
scp-2833 will retain all memories of the
previous instance that released the
parasite they are even able to speak
fluently from the moment they are born
but that isn't the most horrific part
what happens next is that the newborn
scp-2833 will then devour the body of
the female host that carried it
sometimes the host can die before an
scp-2833 is born with the parasite
keeping their body embalmed until the
new instance emerges but regardless the
mother of an scp-2833
will always die during birth the scp
foundation has conducted a number of
interviews with the instances of
scp-2833 that they have captured and
detained the first scp-2830
the man causing civil unrest in him
natargar 1969 referred to himself as we
implying that all of the
scp-2833 instances share the same
consciousness acting as a hivemind of
sorts one of the men from the cemetery
scp-2833-4
elaborated further on the nature of
these anomalous beings when asked how
many of the instances existed we are in
your cages we are distant from the
hordes of the ignorant we are grown like
crops and livestock we are growing in
numbers and faith and we will grow until
the ascension of samadhi
is beyond sight the buried will rise to
be consumed as the doorway to rebirth
this is our cycle waiting for somebody
with patience we shall dance the tandava
and consume the world for its rebirth
samadhi is a word meaning a crypt
usually the final resting place of a
saint or someone of religious
significance additionally the tandava is
an ancient dance that according to
legends was performed by the hindu god
shiva who is believed to be the source
of all things the cycle of creation
preservation and destruction so these
anomalous beings and their parasites
appeared to be awaiting the discovery of
an ancient burial site where someone or
something was prophesized to rise
consume the world and then recreate it
thinking this samdi might pose a threat
the foundation probed a later instance
of
scp-2833 for further information on its
significance if you intend to seek
samadhi your quest is in vain for we are
the inheritor to somebody only we
scp-2833-42
protested when asked about the samadhi
by a foundation researcher one dr sanjay
shiel samadhi does not threaten it is we
who were threatened exiled when the
colossi over and samadhi we are the
remnants and we are never defeated the
instance went on we are of glorious
lineage the chosen stock of carcis
vasquez only the strongest and most
zealous may serve his purpose to that
end we consume ourselves to persist and
await for sanity when asked who exactly
karcist vasquez was
scp-2833-42 answered we are we
are karsus vasque that word karcist has
long been associated with the religious
cult of sarkicism another group of
interests you're likely to be familiar
with if you're a fan of what we do here
this group worships flesh and disease
and is seen as an apocalyptic threat by
the scp foundation the sarkis religion
was founded thousands of years ago by an
ancient elder being known as the
sorcerer king of aritum also called
grand karcist ion the goal of sarkicism
is to bring about a new age of flesh
elevating humanity to the form of gods
and potentially terraforming the entire
earth using scp-610
the flesh that hates so who or what was
karcistvasky what role did it have in
the religion of sarkicism and how does
it link to scp-2833
the foundation has collected a number of
documents once belonging to a man named
sir william henry sleeman sleeman was an
administrator who worked in india on
behalf of the british east india company
before his death in 1856 and it is in
his documents that some of the answers
can be found according to sir william
the poor of india told him about a group
of mystics who were both revered and
feared among the country's peasantry
this group called themselves the vatula
and seemed to hold what slimen described
as an unusual fetish towards death and
decay sounds an awful lot like the
sarcasts doesn't it sir william heard
rumors that these vathullah worshiped
shiva but were never seen at temples
choosing instead to worship the hindu
god in seclusion additionally though
each member of the vatula when asked
identified themselves by the title of
karcist vasque not everyone feared them
however as a group of men would often
attack them these men were thuggy
organized gangs of professional robbers
and murderers that traveled india
strangling their victims to death and
robbing them blind perhaps because of
this the vathullah seemed wary to
interact with any other worshipers of
shiva often dismissing them as
pretenders to the faith hoping to
appease and gain an audience with the
vatula sir william's allies unleashed
what they called the daughter of shadows
better known as scp-029
this divided the thuggy in the hopes
that the vathullah would then accept
sleeman as an ally eventually he
achieved an audience with them and was
unable to determine whether the group
was genuinely devoted to their religious
beliefs or was just a group of madmen
what sir william didn't realize was that
under the vestige of karcist vasque this
group was subtly spreading the influence
of sarkicism over india as for scp-2833
perhaps they are the descendants of the
vatula group their lineage continuing
through the passing of those little
parasites it's highly likely that these
vatula were all early instances of
scp-2833
which would explain why those captured
by the scp foundation claim that they
are all karcist vasquee a few years back
in 2014 one of the foundation's mobile
task forces uncovered a body that was a
genetic match to the other instances of
scp-2833
however this one wasn't found in india
but in krasno-raskai russia
it had strange growths on its muscle
tissue and bones carrying multiple
scp-2833-a parasites inside its internal
organs the body had even been modified
to contain an artificial uterus which
carried an infant scp-2833
instance it seemed that not only have
scp-2833 found a new way to evolve
carrying themselves in a modified body
but they're also beginning to spread
further than ever before you gotta hand
it to the sarcists they're certainly
adaptable now go check out
scp-3989 the bone orchard and scp-610
the flesh that hates for more scary
sarcast scps